what's happening you went off on your
journey Taylor you went crazy on your
attorney
you okay yeah yeah
you're gonna stay here for a minute all
right okay are you able to sit up Taylor
she can bro she's gonna stare at where
she's uh all right
just relax
got your breaths
knew where I was yeah
I'm sorry cameras
Taylor if she was here are you okay
okay he's okay I'm gonna have you sit up
against the door
okay okay we're gonna help you okay so
get your feet underneath you yep
turn towards me
just a little bit no that's okay
all right one two three now slide back
yep all the way to the door on your feet
and just push back there you go there
you go perfect one more big one
you're good
all right
just relax
are you hurt
no you hurt anywhere you wrist no
because I see you got some bruising
no are you tingling in your fingers or
feet or neck no okay
your vision okay
all right
what do you want to do the second floor
holding um
okay because the Aboriginal seven in oh
yeah yeah let's just go to seconds
can you walk oh yeah yeah yeah okay can
you get your shoes on yeah
okay got my favorite
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
oh
you want off on your turn to
you went crazy on your attorney yeah you
can't do that here
you okay yeah
yeah your stage you're gonna stay here
for a minute all right are you able to
sit up Taylor you can well she's gonna
stare
just relax
got two breaths
[Music]
I don't know why you calling me down the
Russian Stadium where I was cameras
Taylor is he was here are you okay
he's okay I'm gonna have you sit up
against the door
okay we're gonna help you okay so get
your feet underneath you yep
turn towards me
just a little bit
more music
all right one two three okay slide back
yep going through the door use your feet
and just push back there you go there
you go perfect
one more big one
you're good
all right
just relax
are you hurt
no you hurt anywhere you rest no because
I see you got some bruising
any tingling in your fingers or feet or
neck no okay
your vision okay
all right
yeah yeah let's just go to seconds okay
can you get your shoes on
get my paper
got it cool fight monitor we're moving
forward
foreign
[Applause]
just relax together okay
you guys probably didn't get it but your
videos just make sure they're on now
you went off on your attorney Taylor you
went crazy on your attorney you can't do
that here
you okay yeah
yeah are you able to sit up stay here
for a minute all right are you able to
sit up Taylor you can well she's gonna
stare
just relax got your breath
s
yeah
okay cameras I'm sorry cameras
Taylor is he was here injury okay
okay but he's okay I'm gonna have you
sit up against the door
okay we're gonna help you we'll get it
so get your feet underneath you
start towards me
just a little bit no that's okay we'll
use it
okay slide back yep I'm all over the
door use your fingers push back there
you go there you go perfect
one more big one
you're good
all right
just relax
are you hurt
you hurt anywhere your wrist no because
I see you got some bruising
and tingling in your fingers or feet or
not
okay
why don't we revision I think we're
ready to move down is there a camera and
everything over
down into the holder
um it's first covered or we might as
well go right here
okay because they're bringing seven in
oh yeah yeah let's just go to seconds or
so and then we'll stand by there Taylor
can you walk oh yeah yeah all right can
you get your shoes on
okay
got it 205 monitor we're moving the
second floor holding for right now
foreign
are they bringing in a bunch of prelims
are we okay there
you go ahead
foreign